hello
my name is marcus kaul and i'm a
professor of biomedical sciences in the
division of biomedical sciences at the
school of medicine at the university of
california and riverside
and today
i want to talk to you about the
connection
of viral infections to neurogeneration
and in particular about two cases of the
role of innate immunity in this instance
so before i get into the topic i do want
to acknowledge um the people who are
helping us with this work currently or
have helped us in the past as well as
the funding sources like the national
institute of health or the national
science foundation that support our work
and
a lot of these
little
you know steps of progress that we make
in research um require a lot of work of
people and a lot of patients and we
really appreciate it and i'm in the
lucky position now to tell you today
about this
so let me start what i want to talk to
you about
we'll first talk a little bit by ground
we'll talk about hiv
then we will talk about the link between
hiv and the brain which is called neural
hiv or neuroaids
or hands which then for hiv associated
neurocognitive disorders you may wonder
why what does the brain have to do with
hiv because hiv
affects the immune system
that is right
and that you will see and then i will
show you some experimental work that
shows the involvement of innate immunity
in neural hiv
and in particular we will talk about the
neurotoxicity of hiv and the role of the
acute phase protein lipocalic too
and then we will talk about some factors
that you might already be a little from
here is interfering beta and what it can
do about interlinear toxicity and in the
end i want to give you a take-home
message
okay so let's get started
hiv human immunodeficiency virus and
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome are
probably two terms that you're familiar
with because aids has really been an
epidemic
and
it has since the early 1980s there's
still about 37.8 million people that are
currently living with hiv they wear the
numbers from 2 um
2020.
so
hiv
infects humans through sexual uh contact
to blood transfusions unfortunately
through needle sharing with stuck abuse
and in attacks particularly
the cd4 cells now the virus itself
actually was discovered in the early
1980s and here we have one of the
original electron micrographs and the
red errors show you what these particles
look like as they emanate from an
infected cell
so
these viruses then bind to the cd4
positive cells and that can be
t cells lymphocytes as well as
macrophages and what happens because of
this a lot of these cells in particular
the lymphocytes will die
so what happens if the cell number goes
below 200 cells per cubic millimeter
then we are talking about a situation
that is described as aids because it is
associated with a major suppression of
the immune system
now that causes a lot of problems and
this was initially in the hiv epidemic a
big problem the
occurrence of opportunistic infections
meaning
that bacteria viruses that are usually
not a problem for a healthy person all
of a sudden cause severe disease
so it was very important therefore that
over the years and it started in the
1980s and drugs were developed that are
now today used as combination
antiretroviral treatment or
therapy
and these drugs are very powerful in
limiting the production of virus
and as a result of this the immune
system can recover there will be more
immune cells
present and that leads at least to the
control
of these opportunistic infections and
people can live quite some time now with
these treatments in fact in many
instances people who
take their anterior wire treatments
regularly and are well
adjusted
may not have any detectable wires in
their system anymore
so all this is fine but let's take a
look at the virus itself
so device as you can see is studded with
the so-called
envelope proteins it itself has a
spherical shape so this is a the hiv is
the prototype for us of a retro um radio
virus
and the order envelope is an is a lipid
matrix
um that is actually taken from the host
cell and we will see in a moment a
little bit more about this
now the amino protein is initially
synthesized as what is called gp160 is
then cleaved into a gb41 and gp120 and
this tp-120 is heavily glycosidic it
casts a lot of carbohydrate or sugars
and this protein is really important
because it is responsible for binding an
entry
of the virus into the host cell but it
is also responsible for the so-called
antigenic drift meaning it sends the
immune system
trying to
restrict the virus on a ghost trace by
constantly changing
so basically this is one of the
strategies how the virus tries to escape
the host immunity
now the genetic information of device
actually is containing two viral
strengths of an rna genome
and this ion genome is surrounded by a
capsid and then there's two trna
molecules that kind of serve as primers
because one of the major characteristics
of these viruses like hiv is that they
have a reverse transcriptase they
reverse transcribe the rna into dna
which is then integrated into the host
cell genome
so and here we see a little bit more of
the life cycle in the upper left we have
again the wires that we see
and we can see that this virus through
the envelope protein is connected to the
host cell which we see in the middle and
there is the molecule cd4 which has been
was found to be the receptor
for the virus and then we see a
chemokine receptor and this is very
important because it took about 15 years
after the discovery of almost 15 years
after the recovery and discovery of the
virus itself to find out that chemokine
receptors are critical in the infection
besides cd4
now
this part already of the biolife cycle
and the connection to the host cell
provides an opportunity to interfere so
we have now a drug it's a so called ccr5
inhibitor monologue that actually blocks
one of these chemokine receptors now
this is very good and it is very
effective
but device can use another chemo
conversator that is called txcl4
so
the next step of device is that it fuses
with the thousand and then again we have
a drug that can potentially interfere
with this and and for really very tight
so after the fusion of device it usually
encodes itself and then reverse
transcription starts and this is a step
where there are a lot of drugs
on the left side the nuclear side rt
inhibitors reverse transcriptase
inhibitors and the non-nuclear
rna inhibitors these are two very
important groups of drugs still today to
prevent reverse transcription they are
very powerful there too
um but the wires can develop in
resistance so this is why we need more
in other drugs
and the next step that we can interfere
is really the integration so the
integrase inhibitors like right here are
relatively new because it took some time
to figure out how to interfere with
system and what the bias accomplishes
with integration is really inserting its
reverse transcribed genome into the host
zone geo so
in a way each viral infection generates
a transgenic cell that produces hiv
if this is successful the virus will
start transcription and so and describe
transcribe its rna and this is that
genomic rna as well as the mrna energy
needs to produce the bioproteins
as we can see here some of these viral
proteins will be in the cell
and the cytosol
and some of them are inserted into this
host cell membrane like the envelope
protein
eventually through some of the
mechanisms that are not in all steps
very well understood the virus will
start to burn
and then um basically bring all its
proteins together at the membrane
and be released and for the virus to
become infectious um it needs a
so-called protease
it needs to once it spuns off it needs
to cleave and score protein to some
extent and this is done by the
bioprotease and there are again
inhibitors for these viral proteins that
are also very powerful in preventing a
virus from becoming infected
so this sounds all great and we have you
know a very good handle on a lot of the
virus
yeah
but there is a problem
and we get to this in the next slide
because the virus
hiv itself
makes its way into the brain and causes
something that was early on called
neuroaids now is called neural hiv
and
the more clinical aspect of this is the
so-called hiv as one associated
neuro-complete disorder
so what is that we have the prevalence
of 37.7
million people and by 2020 living with
hiv
in the us actually alone is an estimated
1.2 million people
and of those
only about 87 actually know that they
are infected
and 66 on the other hand are very
suppressed and they are very successful
treatment
however
30 to 60
of these patients could still experience
neurological complaints and this is
called neuroaids on your hiv
again
the practical or clinical implications
of this are these hand
and they're classically um or clinically
classified as asymptomatic
neurocognitive impairment which is
mildest form than an intermediate mice
neurocognitive disorder or in a
full-blown hiv-associated dementia now
let's look at this what's the link
between the treatment and this diseases
now in the pre-cut era that we see in
this pie chart on the left we see that
you know almost 50 percent of the hiv
patient actually where
had no detectable neurons but more than
20 percent developed dementia
the mitochondria was you know somewhere
between 15 to 20 percent about and a i
was also
very minus form was still you know about
um 25 to
30 percent
now in the cat era then that we see on
the right
you can see the dimension has become a
lot less common it's very rare now and
people live much longer with that
disease the mild neural conditions these
however is still pretty prominent
they're actually slightly higher now and
the minus forms have also increased
so altogether diseases unfortunately
haven't gone away
so
we still need
to
find ways to better understand how this
disease works why does it occur even if
we have very good control about the
virus
now
what happens is
that that autopsy and luckily a lot
fewer people come to autopsy we still
see neuropathological abnormalities in
about 80 of those patients
and these abnormalities are still the
same as in the beaker era loss of
dendrites synapses and pronounced
gliosis that means activation of the
non-neuronal cells in the cns
so how does that work
so this is the work of many labs over a
long time that has contributed to what
i'm going to show you here the model the
mechanistic model of hiv is
neurotoxicity hiv always comes from the
periphery and the stain that it is
carried by infected macrophages into the
cns where it's passed onto mygopia
now these infected microglial cells can
directly affect neurons because they
produce neurotoxins that come from the
host cell but they also release viral
proteins that can
directly work on the neurons what
happens in the neurons as a consequence
of this is that the glutamatergic
neurotransmission is affected and your
glutamatergic neurotransmission is very
important for a normal function of the
brain
so if this is affected and in this case
it looks like it's like over activated
the neurons get into trouble they get
into trouble with their calcium
homeostasis at the cellular level
but they're also trying to counteract
this and what they do is to reduce their
stress from too much glutamine by
reducing your synaptic connections
and that is the step that we think is
the most and the best correlated with
the occurrence of neurocompletive
impairment
now
of course it's not only the microglial
macrophage and neurons that are
affected in the brain these infected
cells
also you know talk to the astrocytes and
astrocytes are very important for
neurotransmission as well because they
regulate growth factors they are
important for glutamate and
neurotransmitter uptake in general
so if these cells become stressed
through
factors that are released by infected
macrophage microbial
they may reduce the amount of growth
factors they produce they may become
impaired in taking up or controlling
user mate and an extinguishers may even
release glutamate or even release
radicals reactive chemical species that
may further stress the neurons
now there is an interesting twist
however um with hiv entering the cns you
need actually very few cells infected
marketplace in myopia because these
infected cells can just shed like the
virus can shed gp 120 or or release
other um
provided proteins and these viral
proteins are sufficient to interact
with
macrophages and migrators are not
infected
and still will be stimulated when you
toxins so we have really a major problem
here from the infected cells but also
from the uninfected
so we're still trying to understand how
that works
and we were hoping that for example fiat
could come in here and stop the bug at
the beginning right when the virus
enters the cns right
so
in principle that sounds very good and
there is a lot of effort on the way to
do that
but the base some practical problems for
one not all of the drugs ended easily
into the brain
the other is that hiv is very fast
very fast reading your brain
we don't have very exact numbers but
some of the evidence indicates that the
virus is it within 24 hours of the
initial infection into the cns
so that means even if you start therapy
very early on in the infection
you may already be behind the virus in
terms of readiness here
so we have been using some tools there
and there are some tools out there is
actually a colleague who more than 20
years ago created a mouse that expressed
hiv gb 120
in the brain
and this is the model that we still use
because it recapitulates a lot of the
events that we see in real life and hrd
pictures
now what we did we ran a big microarray
study what that does mean we looked at
the gene expression in the brains of
these bodies and to make a long story
short
the mice here we would be compared by
the gp120 expressing mice that show
neuropathology and impaired learning and
memory
with the y types do not express gp 120
and show normal learning and memory and
no pathology
so the standard the methods that we used
for running this micro isolating of rna
and running were very established
methods that many people use in science
and the data analysis method is also
it's it's complex because it's a lot of
genes that we look at but it's very well
established methods to do that and what
came out of these experiments were too
really remarkable and unexpected
somewhat unexpected findings
first we found a protein that had never
before been linked to hiv
infection or disease or even
neurocognitive disease at that point
they called libercation too
and
the animal was that we found indication
that an indication that this transgenic
model was actually launching an
interference
so let us look into this a little bit
more because these are very good
examples of how these two components
nipple came into an indifferent beta
which are part of the enablement system
are involved in this
what is slip okay let's start with that
lipoketen is part
of a family of proteins
and
that is why it comes with
several names lipoketen is also known as
zip24 it's an ongoing 24p3 nl in the
mouth but the best known human ortholog
for this is called anger neutrophil
derivative is associated lipokin
it's an acute phase protein that means
it's a protein that can be very quickly
synthesized and activated if something
occurs in a body like an infection
it binds with very high affinity to
lipid lipophilic molecules fatty acids
cholesterol reservoirs process and
important use iron
and it acts in fact as a transporter
carrying small molecules and iron into
an order of cells that express the
receptors
so overall and through studies of many
of our comics and science we know that
the biological functions are
bacteriostatic activity by withdrawing
iron from certain bacteria it doesn't
work against all bacterial strains but
it works against many
we also know now that it defects
neurotransmission the mechanisms are
still not 100 clear
it modulates proliferation and apoptosis
of cells and important for the brain it
activates microbiome and astrocytes
and again important infective disease
and uses chemo concentration
on the right side we see a small model
of this
showing how the cedrophor which is a
lipid
and structure actually forms a kind of a
cage that can bind iron and then is
embedded into lipocallin that a little
bit has the shape of a cup
so in order now to study the the
function of lipoplaning in our model
we crossed mice that like
lipocalyn
with um with a mice that do express
gb120 but before i get into this
i do want to show you a little bit more
about this lipocalend um and here we
looked in brain extracts and you can see
there's quite a lot of this and in this
case what you see here is a ccr5
knockout that was another cross of the
tb120 translated mice that we did and we
can see that this cross doesn't really
change the concentration of lipoprint in
the brain and this was important because
ccr5 is another receptor for the gp-120
so that didn't really make a change but
where is it is synthesized in the brain
now if we did some immunofluorescence
studies we could see that lipopenian is
primarily
found in astrocytes in the middle
image that we can see here in the panel
microglia
didn't have it the neurons didn't seem
to have it it was really the astrocytes
so that speaks to an important role of
astrocytes in this disease as well
so but now
um after we found this in the mouse
we were also wondering okay is it
relevant in real life so and we were
lucky enough
to work together
um or have collaborates that um in the
national neuroace tissue consortium so
this is an organization that since the
beginning of the aids epidemic has been
trying to recruit patients
to agree
to donor dietitians if they pass away
now we received over about 150
samples
rna isolated from the brain from the
middle frontal gyrus an area in the
brain of hiv patients that is highly
affected
by injury
and we were able then also to compare
this to
rna isolated from brains of non-infected
individuals and to see
look for lipokenyan expression and what
we found is that the hiv
brains did have significantly higher
signal expression of lipocalling
so there was a confirmation that
something is going on here but it became
even more interesting
when we looked at these patients and
separated out by those that actually
showed brain pathology hiv brain
pathology versus the asian patient that
didn't show great pathology we could see
that those that had brain personality
are also way higher levels of leukemia
so that was a really clear indication
that lipocallin2 may be associated with
some of the problems that occur in hiv
infection of the brain
so
beyond this there was also when we
looked at the data that the nadc could
provide
that we found that lipocaine correlated
actually with increased hiv dna in the
frontal neocortex
as well as with the increased by load in
the cervical spinal fluid
and finally lipocanning even correlated
with an impairment of one of the
neurocognitive domains which is called
verbal fluency
so this was additional evidence that
lipocanning might be associated with
some of the problems that occur in hiv
infection
so
now we come back to all those model
and here i'm going to tell you a little
bit well we tested whether or not nipple
cannon really couldn't contribute to hiv
and just brain injury so we crossed
lipocany knockout mice with the t120
mice
and we got four genotypes that we had to
analyze over there
and to make a long story short
i shall show you
what
has happened here
we look here at one of the important
reasons when we look at angel linear
pathology and this is synoptic because
synaptophiazin presents presynaptic
terminals
and on the left side we see some of
these immunofluorescence images and yes
if you look at them using how can i ever
tell the difference right yeah there is
some methodology to quantify that
because synoptic phase then
quantification of the lymphatic is a
very good correlate with neural
cognitive impairment so if we look at
the graphs on the right side you can see
that
compared to the wine type the hiv given
20 transgenic might lose
quite a significant amount of synaptic
now
if we look at this in the lipocanyon
about mice we can see that it is the
loss is way lower
and way less yes there is still some
significant loss but it is
significantly less than it would be well
so that clearly indicated that lipopenia
does contribute at least contribute to
that injury it may not be the whole
story but it
clearly contributes in fact if we test
the these animals that like lipophilia
and especially when 20
behaviorally we cannot distinguish them
from the wild type mice so they are
behaviorally basically normal
many aspects
so
and then there was the question how is
it possible that lipocaline protects or
that they're knocked out of liberty
protects right
so and this is some more work and then
showing here here the scheme that
actually summarizes a lot of other
rights when we knock on deep opinion as
we see in the cross and the middle
israeli proclaiming
what happens is
that lipoketen we know can interact with
microbial and micro and can activate
this cell so this no longer occurs
and
there is in the very important um part
here we see this little you know in the
lower right side you see this little
triangle in green tcr5 that represents
cg5 ligands because what happens if we
knock out replicated all of a sudden
the cells that can produce these cclip
ligands
and produce more of these ccr5 ligands
and these ccr5 ligands um that is
something we know from earlier work are
actually neuroprotective and they have
also anti-viral activity
so with these ligands
becoming more available
we can
reduce neuronal damage or largely
prevent neural damage
and
also largely abrogate behavior
alterations so here we have
one
example of how an innate immune factor
that otherwise is very helpful because
it's bacteriostatic it does reduce
um
some of the of the infections that you
can have can in the brain unfortunately
um become a problem if its expression
gets too high
okay now let's shift gears and look at
another important component and this is
also related kind of to the host factor
response
and to hiv technicians interferon alpha
interferons are not specific at all for
hiv
they're coming to play in all kinds of
viral infections but what happens with
hiv and this has been recognized for
some time that there's two major ways
how hiv
can activate the system and this is
shown here in this
in this schematic drawing where the wire
rna um once the virus basically fuses
with the target cell becomes is
recognized by molecules of the innate
immune system
that then signal downstream but the
other way is that the virus is actually
taken up into an anglosome and then it's
recognized by something that is called a
tolerance receptor seven foot now it
will also but through a slightly
different pathway feed into the same
innate immune system and in both
cases
so even so these pathways are
accelerated what we end up having is the
activation
of fetus here ir3 and irf7 and these are
factors that start the interferon
response
the second important factor in this is
nf kappa b nuclear factor copper b
so as a result the cells start to
produce interference in different alpha
and beta these are called the type bond
interference
and these type bonding difference then
will act on the same cell or neighboring
cells by reacting interacting with the
type one interferon receptor
and then a different signal system is
activated like stat pathway
and is the general term for this and
this will
then through these transcription factors
that from the cytosol up on activation
migrate into the nucleus they will start
what is
what is called the isd production the
interference stimulated gene production
so again this is not specific for hiv it
occurs in most infections but the
important thing about the economics is
it generates what is generally called an
antiviral state in the cell isps
enumerate this antioxidant basically a
state where the cell can defend itself
against viral infections
so
this is nice
and we were excited to find in our mouse
model
that there is temporary
expression of indifferent beta in fact
it's pretty low
and it's as you can see here on the left
graph at one point five months these
eyes however show in the brain a
significant increase in difference but
it goes away by three months six months
it's back to baseline
however on the right graph we can see a
molecule that is a very good indicator
that there has been interferon
expression in the competitor expression
and we can see
that the response lasts actually quite
longer it's the highest at 1.5 months
and then it fades over three to six
months away
now why is this of interest
because in humans we actually don't have
this that we don't know exactly what's
happening because we can't look at the
brain in the same way in humans when
there are lives
however there is another model
and the same what we see in the mouth
has been observed in non-human primates
in monkeys that have been affected with
infected with a
relative of hiv the so-called similar
immunodeficiency device we have in those
monkeys we can see the same exact same
thing that there is a transient
expression of interferometer we don't
know yet exactly how this is regulated
why it gets the interferometer away
but what is interesting is that
if the interferometer goes away
then the monkeys get sick and show brain
injury and in the mice also after the
1.5 months we see the development of the
neuropathological changes the behavior
changes take actually even a few months
more to develop so that
raised the question can interfere better
do something
to prevent the injury
and in order to put this to the test
we tried this
in the individual model and we tried to
treat our mice with a different weather
at the time when the endogenous
interference was already gone
and since we wanted to get into the
brain we choose around
through the nose
which is one way how you can actually
target drugs relatively well into the
cns and here's a schematic drawing by
colleagues
who have really studied this in very
much detail that if you apply
interference better in the nose there's
two major ways through the factory
mucosa and the respiratory because how
interference makes its way into the cns
and it's actually very fast
so we tried this treatment
and
for four weeks
um with a relatively high dose
and then we collected the brains
of these mice
and
studied the neuropathology including
neurodendrites the synaptic terminals
but also looked at asteroid astrocytosis
and migraine activation and we also
looked of course at you know are there
interferon or induced genes that are
being expressed in particular some of
the protective factors that we are
interested in
to make a long story short let me give
you just some show some of the data
on the top you see the gene expression
and the vehicle treated versus different
better treated animals
in the wild type on top and then g120
below and what we see here in this first
pair of graphs is that ccl4 and this is
one of the neuroprotective and antiviral
chemokines that the rna for this goes
significantly it is not a dramatic
increase but for the cns that is
actually a quite pronounced increase so
we were very happy to see that
if we look at another factor that is
known to be introduced by 1611 it's also
upregulated it didn't reach significance
and the y type but in the gv12 shelling
at once
as well so it was another indicator that
indifferent better
applied through the nose actually does
work in the cms
and then there is another effect that is
important for having the interferon
response activated and go and keep it
going irf3 which actually was not as
responsive in the wine type as it was
actually in the presence of the gb120
that causes the neurotoxicity
interestingly so however
the gb120 did not
budge due to the different better the
expression of the wire protein itself
did not change which is not so
surprising because it's not driven by a
wire promoter it's in this model driven
by a host sub promoter
okay so but we also know from this that
whatever effect we see is not because
the expression of gb120
now
to look at what happens in the from
better treatment let's again look at
presynaptic terminals and some neuronal
dendrites
here again some of the images and again
you would say oh how i can't really see
a difference so you really need to
quantify these data and if you see the
quant if you quantify this then you can
see in the cortex on the left and the
hippocampus on the right
that only the vehicle treated gp120 mice
do show a loss of presynaptic terminals
whereas the interfering banner treated
have a slightly higher or no loss of
these presynaptic terminals so that
speaks at least the synaptic terminals
are protected
the other important reader is the neural
dendrites again pictures here where
you're just looking at this you may not
be able to tell the difference but if
you quantify it you see again
that in cortex on the left and the
hippocampus on the right that only the
vehicle treats it but not the
interference better treated g120 mice
lose
um significant amounts of the neuronal
dendrites so that overall
was a good news for us in necessary
because it indicated that indifferent
beta can really be protective in the cns
and this is also perhaps for some of you
may remember that interference actually
proved to treat another important cns
disease multiple sclerosis where it is
also protective
in there so in this case it might play
into the world that what in different
beta here don't it's not specific
necessarily for hiv but it seems to have
a protective effect in the context of
hiv infection of the cfs
so if we put the stones right now
together
and again this summarized a lot more
what we found out then all together was
that indifferent better
seems to work
through the
receptor for type 1 interference which
is called if i want and it works on all
cell types it's the neurons the
astrocytes and the microbial but it
looks like it's the and astrocenter
migration that produce
this factor called ccl4
among other vectors
which is very protective and this
respect actually goes back to ccr5 this
was the receptor that we looked at
earlier one of the core receptors for
hiv so one of the core receptors for hiv
is not only a receptor for hiv but it's
also an important receptor actually for
an antiviral chemokine
and downstream of this important for
survival is the activation of a pathway
that's called that is driven by
an enzyme called pkd akt and leads to
neuroprotection
so the take home message then from what
i told you today is
that innate immune factors can promote
or prevent
hiv sources neurogenerative brain injury
and
neuroangine in this case and the second
part is that the interaction of neuronal
and lines viruses plays a critical role
in this context
this index is not only important for
neurotransmission like astrocytes
regulating the neurotransmission or
likelihood of neural transmission but
it's also very important in the immune
response of the cnn
and this concludes my talk
thank you very much for your attention
goodbye